♪.
RACHEL: WELCOME BACK TO
"FOX & FRIENDS."
SHOCKING PICTURES REVEALING THE
HORRIFYING REALITY OF THE CRISIS
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
TEXAS AGENTS ON PATROL
DISCOVERING 40 MIGRANTS BEING
HAULED IN A TRAILER WHILE
TRAPPED IN A METAL BOX WITH NO
MEANS OF ESCAPE.
IT COMES AS AN ESTIMATED 18,000
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE SET TO
ENTER OUR COUNTRY EVERY DAY WHEN
TITLE 42 ENDS.
WITH BORDER TOWNS FEARING THE
BRUNT OF THE INFLUX.
DEMOCRAT PRO TEM, THE MAYOR OF
EAGLE PASS, TEXAS, YO LAUNDRA
ROMAN, JOINS US NOW.
MAYOR, SO GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON
THIS MORNING.
BEFORE TITLE 42 IS LIFTED, TELL
ME WHAT IS THE IMPACT RIGHT NOW
ON YOUR COMMUNITY?
>> GOOD MORNING, RACHEL.
I'M THE MAYOR PRO TEM.
I'M NOT THE MAYOR OF EAGLE PASS.
IT IS AFFECTING US IN MANY, MANY
WAYS.
BEFORE THAT, I'VE SAID BEFORE
YOU KNOW, SMALL COMMUNITY,
WORKING PEOPLE, YOU KNOW PEOPLE
THAT WE GO BACK AND FORTH TO THE
BORDER BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
FAMILY, FRIENDS JUST ACROSS THE
BORDER.
WE'RE RIGHT THERE WITH THE --
RACHEL: SURE.
>> THE WAY IT IS GOING TO IMPACT
US IF THIS, IF THEY PUT AN END
TO TITLE 42, WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE, WE DON'T HAVE
THE MANPOWER.
WE DON'T HAVE THE FACILITIES.
WE ARE NOT EQUIPPED TO HANDLE
THE INFLUX OF PEOPLE THAT WILL
COME IN.
WE'RE LOOKING AT TWO, THREE,
TIMES, MANY TIMES MORE THAN WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW.
AS IT IS RIGHT NOW.
WE CAN, WE CAN'T HANDLE IT.
PEOPLE HAVE SAID, IT IS BEING
MANAGED CORRECTLY, BUT, I CAN
TELL YOU, YOU KNOW, FROM BEING
HERE, FROM SEEING IT FIRST-HAND,
INTEREST IS -- THERE IS A LOT
MORE THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
RACHEL: HAS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OFFERED YOUR
COMMUNITY ANY RESOURCES?
>> NOT THAT I KNOW OF.
I GUESS I WOULD KNOW.
I'M ON THE CITY COUNCIL.
WE DON'T HAVE -- WE NEED
RESOURCES, WE NEED A LOT OF
HELP.
WE SEE A LOT OF BORDER PATROL,
U.S. CUSTOMS.
WE SEE, I'M ASSUMING PEOPLE THAT
COME FROM ARMY NATIONAL GUARD,
YOU KNOW, WE JUST HAD A TRAGIC
DEATH FOR ONE OF OUR NATIONAL
GUARD MEMBERS, THAT TRIED TO
SAVE SOMEONE.
WE SEE A LOT OF THAT, BUT EVEN
THEN WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES.
THEY'RE SENT HERE.
NEED HELP TO DO A JOB BUT WE AS
A CITY DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO TAKE CARE OF THIS.
IT NEEDS TO BE HANDLED IN A
DIFFERENT WAY.
I THINK WE ALL KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THAT.
IT NEEDS TO BE IMMIGRATION.
IT IS REFORM HAS BEEN WAITING
TOO LONG.
IT IS LONG OVERDUE, MORE LIKE 40
YEARS OVERDUE, YOU KNOW.
THAT IS KIND OF HELP WE NEED.
RACHEL: THE ADMINISTRATION SEEMS
DETERMINED TO LIFT TITLE 42 AND
YOU'RE SAYING THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
GOING TO BE TRAGIC FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY.
WHAT IS YOUR COMMUNITY TELLING
YOU AND WHAT ARE THEY WORRIED
ABOUT MOST SPECIFICALLY?
>> OUR COMMUNITY TELL US IT IS
NOT US.
SOME PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY,
SOME PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND IT
IS NOT US.
COUNCIL MEMBERS, AS YOU KNOW,
THEY KEEP CALLING US, NO, WHY
ARE YOU LETTING -- WHAT ARE YOU
TAKING CARE OF?
WE NEED TO EXPLAIN IT IS NOT US.
IT DOESN'T COME FROM US.
IT IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
REALLY THERE IS NOT MUCH WE CAN
DO.
WE'RE ASKING PRESIDENT BIDEN
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO HIM,
WE'RE ASKING TO PLEASE, YOU
KNOW, MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A
STOP TO THIS BECAUSE, I MEAN,
EVERYONE, EVERYONE FROM
WASHINGTON TO COME DOWN TO EAGLE
PASS.
WE'RE A SMALL COMMUNITY.
WE PUT A LOT INTO THE NATIONAL
ECONOMY THROUGH OUR BRIDGES.
IMPORT, EXPORT TO MEXICO.
WE INVITE HIM TO COME.
TO SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING TO,
ACTUALLY COME AND SEE IN PERSON.
NOT JUST THROUGH TV.
YOU KNOW.
RACHEL: RIGHT.
>> IT IS NOT GOOD FOR THE
IMMIGRANTS, THEIR FAMILIES,
COMING.
IT IS NOT GOOD FOR US.
AGAIN OUR COMMUNITY NEEDS TO BE,
WE'RE A SMALL, SAFE COMMUNITY.
I DON'T THINK CITIZENS IN EAGLE
PASS THAT IS THEIR CONCERN.
THEY DON'T FEEL SAVE ANYMORE.
RACHEL: JUST REALLY QUICK, I
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME.
I WANT TO MAKE THIS REALLY
CLEAR.
YOUR CITIZENS ARE NOT FEELING
SAFE.
THEY FEEL LIKE INCREASE IN CRIME
OR INSECURITY IN THEIR FEELINGS
OF SAFETY.
ARE YOUR HOSPITALS OVERRUN?
ARE YOUR, WHAT OTHER RESOURCES
ARE YOU EXPERIENCING, IS YOUR
COMMUNITY EXPERIENCING THAT
CONCERNS THEM?
>> YOU KNOW THERE IS A LOT OF
CONCERN FROM THE PEOPLE, FROM
THE CITIZENS.
THE HOSPITALS ARE DEFINITELY
OVERRUN BECAUSE EVERY PERSON
THAT COMES ACROSS THEY'RE BEING
TAKEN OVER THERE, AGAIN.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THE FINANCIAL
SITUATION, WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES FOR THE HOSPITAL WORKS
BUT AGAIN LIKE ANY OTHER
BUSINESS I'M SURE THEY DON'T
HAVE WHAT THEY NEED TO HAVE.
IT IS JUST SCARY AS YOU CAN SEE
FOR US.
IT IS JUST SOMETHING THAT
DEFINITELY NEEDS TO BE TAKEN
CARE OF YOU KNOW?
YOU NEED TO BE HERE IN OUR TOWN
TO BE ABLE TO SEE WHAT WE'RE
SEEING AND WHAT IS HAPPENING.
EXACTLY WHAT THAT LADY DID,
PEOPLE JUMPING INTO THE RIVER,
AND BORDER PATROL EXPECTED TO
SAVE THEM.
THAT ISN'T SAFE FOR ANYBODY, A
LOT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
RACHEL: THEY SAID THEY WOULD BE
COME TO THE BORDER, KAMALA
HARRIS, BORDER CZAR.
YET TO COME.
I FEEL YOUR FRUSTRATION, COMING
ON THE SHOW TOD